بعد تشريح القرش القاتل عقب مهاجمته
للسائح الروسي بمياه الغردقه خبير يكشف عن
اسباب الهجوم
الدكتور محمود دار الاستاذ بالمعهد القومي
المصري لعلوم البحار فرع البحر الاحمر كشف
عن ان سمكه القرش من نوع النمر التي تم
تشريحها على يد مجموعه من المتخصصين
امعائها فارغه تماما باستثناء بعض اشلاء
جثه الشاب الضحيه
[موسيقى]
هذا النوع من الاسماك يعيش في اعماق تصل
الى 20 مترا تخرج للمناطق القريبه من
الشاطئ في ثلاث حالات اولها عندما تلقي
بعض المراكب الحيوانات النافقه في المياه
اما الحاله الثانيه عندما يقدم اصحاب
المراكب طعاما لاسناك القرش ما يغير من
طبيعه تغذيتها وفي الحاله الثالثه هي خروج
سمكه القرش بوضع مواليدها في المناطق
الامنه خوفا عليها من الذكور او الاعداء
وتقوم انثى القرش بتامين المنطقه وزيارتها
قبل وضع المواليد والسمكه تكون في حاله
هياج لانها تشعر بالخطر على مواليدها ولا
تاكل حتى تضع الوليد
وقال الدكتور ان السمكه تنفذ غريزتها
الطبيعيه بوضع مواليدها في مكان امن واذا
وجدت اي كائن حي سواء انسان او غيره تصاب
بحاله من الهيار وتهاجمه لشعورها بالخطر
[موسيقى]